ready to leave the Vault Amazon's new
Fallout series is nearly here and the
first trailer is packed full of
fan-friendly details Amazon Studios has
dropped the first teaser trailer for its
Fallout Series this iconic
post-apocalyptic RPG series continues to
be one of the most popular video game
franchises of all time although the
series debuted in 1997 it was 2008's
highly immersive Fallout 3 that turned
the series into a must playay for gamers
for the UN initiative players take on
the role of an individual living in a
made to withstand nuclear fallout
through various circumstances they force
out of their comfort zone and enter an
apocalyptic hellscape confronting
devious humans and terrifying creatures
The Fallout television adaptation which
comes from Westworld creatives Lisa Joy
and Jonathan Nolan will be an original
story that's canonical to the video
games based purely on the first look of
the Series Hardcore fans will be pleased
with the show's Direction the teas a
trailer is ripe with imagery and
iconography that's ripped directly from
the video game such as the iconic look
of the The Vault and post-apocalyptic
Earths many dly creatures there are
however some small but important details
that fans might have missed in this
first
trailer I grabbed a moldy one more The
Fallout games take place in the same
universe and timeline they're not
necessarily interconnected like
traditional sequels however the games
feature similar themes mechanics and
sometimes characters perhaps one of the
most interesting characters in the
franchise is dog meat a dog who serves
as a companion for the playable
character dog meet has become a
prominent part of the Fallout law which
is why it shouldn't be surprising that
he's set to make an appearance in the
Amazon's adaptation and it seems like
dog meet is making more than just a
cameo appearance in the Fallout series
as he appears a number of times
throughout the trailer featuring dog
meet in the series directly ties the
show to the video games making his
appearance a truly fun piece of fan
service and seeing as there's a
different dog meet in each game the
creatives have card blanch to create a
version of the dog that perfectly suits
the television series meanwhile in the
The Fallout laww there are over 100
vaults though not all of them have been
explored in the games with the release
of the television series fans are on
track to see a brand new Vault that
hasn't appeared before in the trailer
audiences see the protagonist Lucy leave
Vault 33 and set up for the outside
world for reasons as yet unknown little
is known about Vault 33 which is what
makes it all the more intriguing the
vault is located in what was once Los
Angeles which makes sense considering
vaults with low numbers were built for
the West Coast however it looks like
something devious is being cooked up at
Vault 33 when we see Lucy step out of
Vault 33 for the first time a cut can be
seen on her lip did she get into a fight
if so with whom another moment appears
to depict total bedum happening in a
vault though whether it's Vault 33 isn't
yet known The Fallout series isn't
shying away from showing that things are
imperfect in both the sheltered and
outside world and it seems that the
series will carry on this theme notably
Fallout will be set in the year
2296 about 200 years after the
Apocalypse the year in which the show is
set as important as it helps inform fans
of when the show takes place in the
larger Fallout timeline the franchise's
last Mainline entry Fallout 4 is set in
2287 which means the television series
begins after all the games still the
show features components seen throughout
the franchise these include the power
armors a key aspect of the franchise in
terms of gameplay and visual recognition
fans will also spot the military group
Brotherhood of Steel the symbol can be
seen on the power armors another key
piece of iconography ripped from the
games as a Verte bird flying vehicle
first introduced in Fallout 2 the
vehicles are seen briefly in the trailer
based purely on the trailer Fallout
seems like it would be an authentic
adaptation that honors its source
material while offering a unique story
and while fans no doubt have questions
about the series all will be answered
when Fallout its Prime video on April
12th